let's go next to joseph from oregon
joseph you're on the air
hi david uh thanks for taking my call i
appreciated your i appreciated your
coverage of the state of the union
last night and uh the other night
um and i just wanted to ask a question
kind of about what um kind of the
strategy for dems and what they do going
forward okay it sounded like the speech
was
vague and
understandably optimistic
but overall it sounded like it was aimed
at de-leaning conservatives and
centrists
and maybe without like the four things
biden mentioned with like the opioid
crisis
beating uh having better mental health
supporting our veterans and ending
cancer
it didn't really sound like there was an
actual plan for those things and maybe
other than the opioid crisis i'm not
sure
if any of those items on the agenda are
really that popular so with the midterms
coming up like
what do you think the strategy should be
for the dems to get a strong swing back
in time for the midterms i i actually
think that it's less about strategy but
it's about you gotta get something done
and i completely agree with you and one
of my critiques after the state of the
union was i think joe biden's rhetoric
on the foreign policy piece particularly
russia ukraine was strong uh i think it
it ended strong there were some good
moments in the middle but um the the
sort of like
listing what was probably like a dozen
different things i mean he talked about
the four things you mentioned he talked
about controlling prices for industries
charging too much talked about doing the
taxes where the rich in corporations
will pay more
there was all this this list of stuff
almost all of which has no path to
happening certainly in the next year if
at all under joe biden's presidency
sadly i wish it were different and um
the one place i disagree with you is i
think the whole point of those four
things biden mentioned
was that while they might not be the
issues the audience is most passionate
about they're sort of like
uncontroversial like who doesn't want to
end cancer although some republicans
didn't even clap for that which is crazy
but i think it was deliberate to create
some moments where everybody appears to
be on the same page so rhetorically i
understand it although i agree with you
that it's like those aren't the top
issues for most people i get that so i
think it was okay like i said i gave it
a b
yeah sorry and i realized i i meant to
say too like of course like beating like
everyone wants to end cancer like that's
a popular thing i just don't think like
you should legislate your way through
cancer no probably not probably not
that's fair so that's fair
thank you for taking my call my pleasure
great to hear from you let's take a very
quick break we're not done with phone
calls so if you still want to talk to me
don't hang up because we're going to go
right back to the phones in a moment
one of our long time sponsors is vincero
collective i love vincero's watches
you've heard me talk about them before
they now offer sunglasses and a bunch of
other premium accessories for men and
women vincero is committed to creating
exceptionally crafted watches and
accessories and doing so ethically fair
pricing carbon neutrality vincero puts
their principles first which is
important to me i just picked up the
rogue from vincero in gunmetal and red i
love the intricate design on the watch
face and the multiple sub dials the
durable black silicone strap looks great
with just about anything i'm wearing in
all of vincero's products whether it's
the watches the glasses men's or women's
you can just see and feel the quality so
if you want to elevate your look or you
want to find the perfect valentine's day
gift for that special someone pick
something up at vincero vincero
collective is giving my audience 15 off
all products and free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below